Catedrática Tamar Gendler: En la
clase de hoy quiero hablar sobre
la corriente de la tradición
filosófica que no se centra en la forma
en que las interrelaciones humanas
pueden proporcionar significado
y la posibilidad de prosperar,
sino en un cierto tipo de desapego
psicológico como una forma
de enfrentarse a las
vicisitudes de la vida.
La expresión más clara de la
perspectiva que estudiaremos hoy
en el contexto de la
tradición occidental
puede encontrarse en los escritos
del filósofo Epicteto.
Este es un maravilloso retrato
imaginario de él de 1715,
sentado en una mesa, con su famoso
bastón que usaba para caminar
debido a su cojera.
En la guía de lectura vieron
que Epicteto vivió a
principios de hace dos siglos.
Vivió aproximadamente del año 50
al 130 de la era común.
Nació en la zona de habla
griega de Asia Menor
y vivió en el imperio
romano de esa época.
Fue esclavo la primera parte de su vida.
No está claro si fue
esclavo hasta los 13
o hasta los 27, en cualquier caso,
fue esclavo una buena parte de su vida.
Finalmente, obtuvo la libertad
y antes o después de eso
estudió los trabajos
y el panorama filosófico de una
tradición conocida como estoicismo.
Sobreviven dos trabajos
producidos en su nombre.
El primero es una importante
colección de volúmenes
de sus discusiones sobre temas variados:
la metafísica, cómo es el mundo,
la epistemología, cómo
deberíamos entender el mundo
y la ética.
Además, sobrevive el libro
extraordinario que leímos para hoy.
El pequeño ensayo de 45 epígrafes
conocido como El manual,
que al parecer igual que los
textos de Aristóteles,
fue registrado por uno de los alumnos de
Epicteto y así se conservó.
El Manual de Epicteto
ha tenido gran influencia
en los 2000 años
que ha pertenecido a la
tradición occidental.
El frontispicio que les mostré
con la imagen de Epicteto
lo obtuve de la
biblioteca de John Adams,
el segundo presidente de
los Estados Unidos,
quien tenía en su colección la edición
en latín de 1715 de este libro.
Esperen a que pase el eclipse.
Otra cosa histórica interesante
del volumen que estamos leyendo es que
la primera traducción a inglés
la hizo una gran mujer de la literatura
del siglo XVIII, Elizabeth Carter.
Aunque la traducción que
estamos leyendo
es una versión más moderna.
En este texto, Epicteto recoge
muchos de los principios del
estoicismo clásico.
Hasta ahora hemos visto en esta
clase la obra de Platón,
que es un filósofo sistemático.
Tiene opiniones de todo y
está comprometido
con cierto tipo de filosofía
racionalista, formalista e idealista.
Hemos visto la obra de Aristóteles
a través de uno de sus
libros: Ética a Nicómaco.
Pero, junto a esas 2 tradiciones,
la de Platón y la de Aristóteles,
el mundo filosófico antiguo produjo
otra serie de panoramas
filosóficos sistemáticos
con opiniones acerca
de casi cualquier cuestión.
Entre ellos está el estoicismo.
Los estoicos consideraban,
con respecto a los hechos metafísicos
subyacentes de la realidad,
que el mundo es una totalidad
física orgánica gobernada
por lo que ellos llamaban
logos o razón divina.
Hay un orden en el mundo.
La responsabilidad de los humanos,
dado que existe ese orden,
es cultivar una virtud en particular.
En la idea estoica, la virtud es actuar
según lo que la razón te dice
que la naturaleza demanda.
Ir junto con este gran esquema de cosas,
no tratar de luchar contra lo que
está predestinado para ti.
No es de sorprender que algunos
elementos de la tradición estoica
se recojan en tradiciones
teístas posteriores.
La visión estoica de que el mundo
es una entidad bien ordenada
gobernada por la razón divina
está en el corazón de muchas
tradiciones religiosas
que ustedes conocen.
Entonces, la pregunta es
¿qué se exige de ustedes
según los preceptos?
¿Qué deben hacer si esas
cosas son ciertas?
Los estoicos sugieren que tienen
que aceptar su destino,
que es la consecuencia del poder
y la bondad del logos,
aunque es posible que ustedes
no puedan ver los beneficios.
Tienen que moderar sus deseos,
evitar el exceso de sentimientos
y actuar según la razón.
El uso contemporáneo del
término estoico,
alguien que no expresa
sufrimiento ante el dolor,
recoge el segundo aspecto normativo.
Es importante reconocer,
al igual que con los otros
filósofos que estamos leyendo,
que esto es parte de una visión
sistemática del mundo.
La idea no es tomar un poco de
aquí y otro poco de allá
sin preocuparnos de cómo se combinan.
La idea es que tenemos un
concepto de la naturaleza
fundamental de la realidad, una
opinión de cómo sabemos esto
y las opiniones de qué debemos
hacer en consecuencia.
En El Manual, Epicteto solo se preocupa
por una pequeña porción de
la visión estoica.
Básicamente, le preocupa
escribir el primer manual de autoayuda.
Intenta explicar a los
ciudadanos de la antigua Roma
del año 100 qué deben hacer
si quieren prosperar.
Esto es lo que dice que deben hacer.
Necesitan aprender a responder
apropiadamente a sus experiencias
haciendo 3 cosas:
Necesitan alterar sus
percepciones del mundo
para que puedan percibir las cosas
sin que les influyan de
forma perjudicial.
Necesitan alterar sus deseos
con respecto al mundo.
Necesitan estructurar su vida
para mantenerse por el buen camino;
necesitan estructurar sus
relaciones sociales
para que les ayuden a
sustentar sus compromisos.
En la siguiente diapositiva,
hice el intento de
ayudarles a leer el texto
sugiriendo formas de poner cada uno
de los subpasajes del libro
dentro de estas categorías.
Por ejemplo, cuando Epicteto nos dice
que tenemos que alterar nuestra
percepción del mundo,
hay 3 formas específicas que
él sugiere para hacerlo,
3 componentes para esta instrucción.
La primera es que tenemos que
clasificar correctamente
las cosas en 2 categorías: cosas
sobre las que tenemos control,
hablaremos más de esto en un rato,
y cosas sobre las que no
tenemos control.
Necesitamos establecer
nuestra taxonomía.
También necesitamos anticipar la forma
en que el mundo suele revelarse.
No basta con saber qué cosas
dependen de nosotros
y qué cosas no;
con respecto a las cosas que no
dependen de nosotros,
necesitamos estructurar
nuestras expectativas
para estar preparados emocionalmente
para lo que se nos pueda presentar.
Repito, hablaré más de esto después.
Y necesitamos reconocer,
de alguna manera esto es una
subdivisión de lo primero,
el papel que juegan el juicio y la
elección al determinar
si la experiencia nos afecta.
Esas son las 3 cosas que Epicteto
dice que necesitamos hacer
con respecto a la percepción,
daré ejemplos de cada una
en un rato más.
Veamos la segunda cosa que
necesitamos hacer.
Epicteto nos dice que necesitamos
cultivar los deseos apropiados.
Necesitamos alinear nuestros
deseos con el mundo
para no frustrarnos constantemente.
La forma de hacerlo consiste en
invertir la relación estándar
entre los deseos y el mundo.
Por lo general, los deseos no
expresan cómo son las cosas
sino cómo desearíamos que fueran.
Ayer, deseé con todas mis fuerzas que
hoy no fuera el 8º día de nevada
en 3 semanas para mis hijos.
Pero el mundo se negó a
cooperar al respecto.
Si hubiera ajustado mis deseos al
mundo, si hubiera deseado
que las cosas pasaran tal y como
logos lo pronosticara,
entonces, estaría contenta de tener
a mis hijos en mi oficina.
La segunda estrategia que
Epicteto nos da
para cultivar los deseos correctos
consiste en usar la
extraordinaria capacidad
humana
de asimilar cosas de una
categoría con cosas de otra.
Recuerden cuando les enseñé la
tarea de selección de Wason,
aquel experimento curioso en el que
había una A, una F, un 4 y un 7,
y les pregunté qué carta
debíamos voltear
para ver si era verdad que si de
un lado había una A,
del otro lado había un 7.
Esa tarea era difícil,
pero cuando les mostré otra tarea
con la misma estructura,
con 4 cartas que tenían edades
y bebidas alcohólicas y
no alcohólicas,
y les pregunté qué
cartas debían voltear
para verificar si era verdad que si
alguien está bebiendo cerveza
es porque es mayor de 21 años.
De repente, fueron capaces de
entender el problema difícil
a la luz del otro problema que
les interesaba más.
Epicteto destaca que tenemos la
habilidad para prescindir de cosas.
Tenemos la habilidad para establecer
una distancia psicológica.
Tenemos la habilidad para decir:
"Bueno, estas cosas pasan,
pero no importa".
Daré ejemplos más adelante
de cómo sugiere Epicteto
que aprendamos a asimilar las cosas
que nos cuesta trabajo superar
con las cosas que nos parecen fáciles
y así explotar la capacidad que tenemos
de entendimiento metafórico.
Por último en esta categoría,
Epicteto señala la importancia
de habituarnos a la pérdida inevitable.
Tengo malas noticias para todos ustedes.
Todos van a morir.
Shelly Kagan tiene todo un
curso dedicado a esto,
sobre cómo aceptar este
hecho inevitable
de la experiencia humana.
Epicteto sugiere que asumamos
esto por completo,
no solo al nivel de poder
pronunciar las palabras
"algún día voy a morir", sino al nivel
de realmente habituar esa idea a
nuestras relaciones con las cosas.
De repente, las cosas que
parecían muy importantes
dejan de serlo.
Por último, Epicteto señala
que si van a actuar
de formas que van en contra de
las normas de su cultura,
es importante darse cuenta
de que van a recibir
comentarios negativos de la sociedad.
Pasaje tras pasaje
describe la importancia
de resistir a la presión social.
Cuando la gente diga: "¡No estás
buscando el honor y la gloria!
¡Eres un fracasado!".
Epicteto aconseja: "Deja que hablen
y que no te importe lo que digan de ti".
Como indico aquí,
hay casi 15 pasajes en los que se
identifica esta estrategia.
Finalmente, Epicteto les da
una especie de truco,
un personaje que recomienda cultivar.
Espera que sean una persona callada:
la gente dice cosas y ustedes se
mantienen calmados y no responden.
Esta estrategia que nos presenta
tiene 3 partes principales.
En la siguiente parte de la clase
quiero repasar algunos ejemplos
específicos de esto,
viendo primero el texto de
Epicteto, citándolo directamente
y después sugiriendo algunas
analogías contemporáneas
de lo que está diciendo.
El primer párrafo de El
Manual de Epicteto
es uno de los fragmentos más famosos
de los textos filosóficos
de la tradición occidental de
los últimos 2000 años.
Comienza así:
"Algunas cosas dependen nosotros
y algunas no.
Nuestras opiniones dependen de
nosotros, nuestros impulsos,
nuestros deseos, nuestras aversiones,
en resumen, todas nuestras
propias acciones.
Pero nuestros cuerpos no dependen
de nosotros, es decir,
nuestras partes físicas,
nuestras posesiones,
nuestra reputación,
nuestros cargos públicos,
todo lo que no sean nuestras
propias acciones".
Epicteto continúa y destaca un
error que podemos cometer.
"Las cosas que dependen de nosotros,
son libres por naturaleza,
sin trabas y sin obstáculos.
Las que no dependen de nosotros están
esclavizadas por naturaleza,
tienen trabas y no son nuestras.
Si piensan que las cosas
esclavizadas por naturaleza,
las que no dependen de ustedes,
son suyas, que las cosas
esclavizadas por naturaleza son
libres
o que las cosas que no son
suyas, son suyas,
estarán frustrados,
tristes, desilusionados
y andarán por ahí culpando al mundo
de todo lo malo que les pasa".
El error de confundir aquello
sobre lo que tienen control
con aquello sobre lo que no, los
llevará a sentirse frustrados,
enojados, tristes y culpables.
Por el contrario,
mantener estas categorías en
claro brinda el mejor premio:
"Si piensan que solo lo suyo es suyo,
que lo que no les pertenece
no les pertenece,
nadie podrá coaccionarlos nunca, nadie
podrá ser un obstáculo nunca.
No culparán a nadie.
No acusarán a nadie.
No harán una sola cosa en
contra de su voluntad…"
Porque las únicas cosas sobre las
que buscan tener control
son las cosas sobre las que en
realidad tienen control.
En consecuencia, "nadie
puede coaccionarlos"
porque solo les preocupan las cosas
que dependen de ustedes.
"Nadie puede ser un obstáculo"
porque nadie puede interferir
en las cosas que dependen de ustedes.
Cualquiera que tenga un
amigo, un familiar
o un conocido que haya
participado en una
de las múltiples versiones
contemporáneas de Epicteto,
en un programa de autoayuda,
sabe que en el corazón de la
tradición contemporánea
de los 12 pasos está el
pensamiento de Epicteto,
expresado como oración,
tal vez por primera vez por
Reinhold Niebuhr.
Es la oración de la serenidad
que pueden encontrar decorada con
colibríes y narcisos.
"Dios, dame serenidad
para aceptar las cosas que
no puedo cambiar,
valor para cambiar las cosas
que sí puedo cambiar
y sabiduría para
distinguir la diferencia".
Si las bellezas matutinas
no son su estilo,
la pueden encontrar
decorada con un perro.
O un ángel. O una niña.
Pueden encontrarla en un tazón, o
más sorprendentemente,
tatuada en sus brazos, en sus
muslos o en sus costados.
Sin duda, hay algo de la
idea de Epicteto
que habla a la mente contemporánea.
Tan es así que cuando hice la
búsqueda de imágenes en Google
de "oración de la serenidad"
encontré miles de imágenes como esta
en todos los idiomas que
puedan imaginarse.
La idea de que necesitamos diferenciar
entre las cosas que podemos
cambiar y las que no,
y que una actitud de aceptación
es lo apropiado hacia las cosas
que no podemos cambiar,
mientras que una actitud de
fortaleza es apropiada
para las cosas que sí podemos cambiar,
es una lección que Epicteto ha
ofrecido a la tradición occidental.
Segundo ejemplo.
Epicteto nos habla de la importancia
de la regulación emocional
a través de la anticipación
de lo que nos pasará
en una situación determinada.
Dice: "Supongamos que vas a
los baños públicos.
Cuando vas a hacer alguna acción,
recuérdate a ti mismo qué
tipo de acción es.
¿Vas a bañarte?
¡Piensa lo que pasa en los baños!
Hay gente que salpica, hay
gente que empuja
y hay gente que insulta".
Si van al aeropuerto,
recuerden que tendrán que
hacer largas filas.
Si están preparados para el hecho de
que van a estar ahí sentados
esperando su vuelo, podrán
ajustar sus emociones.
"Repite para ti, quiero ir
a darme un baño".
Quiero ir al aeropuerto.
Quiero caminar por el campus en
las banquetas congeladas.
"Quiero hacer esto de tal forma
que mis elecciones estén de
acuerdo con la naturaleza".
Si esperan apropiadamente que
las cosas sean como son,
no se frustrarán.
Quiero caminar por el campus.
Es un día helado.
Me doy cuenta de que para caminar por
el campus en un día helado,
tendré que deslizar mis pies
en vez de levantarlos.
Lo que antes me molestaba
se vuelve un simple hecho del
mundo que no puedo controlar
y por lo tanto, no perturba
mi tranquilidad.
La tercera cosa que sugiere
Epicteto es que reconozcamos
que lo que nos molesta no son
las cosas que pasan
sino nuestros juicios sobre esas cosas.
Recuerden que cuando les
mostré la pintura
que hay en el Museo Metropolitano
de la muerte de Sócrates
con el cáliz de cicuta les dije
que una muerte noble,
registrada por un buen agente
de relaciones públicas
-algo cierto sobre Sócrates
y sobre un carpintero de Nazareth-
puede servir como piedra de toque
para las creencias de la gente
de cómo enfrentarse a la vida humana
y a sus cosas inevitables.
Epicteto dice: "Lo que disgusta a
la gente no son las cosas,
sino sus juicios acerca de esas cosas.
Por ejemplo, la muerte en sí misma no
tendría que ser algo terrible.
Si fuera terrible, el sabio Sócrates
habría sentido que era terrible".
Epicteto dice que lo terrible de la
muerte no es la muerte en sí misma.
Lo que es terrible de la muerte
es el juicio de que la
muerte es terrible.
Nada es dañino en sí mismo.
Depende de ti si dejas
que te perjudique.
Cuando enseñas a tu hijo a no enojarse
por las burlas desconsideradas de
sus compañeros de clase,
le enseñas
que lo que dicen sus
compañeros no puede lastimarlo
a menos de que le moleste
emocionalmente.
Si no dejas que te lastime,
no te puede lastimar.
Esto se expresa
-aquí está Laurence Olivier
interpretando a Hamlet-
en la famosa escena de Rosencranz
y Guildenstern de Hamlet,
la pongo aquí porque sé que
habrá una producción
de Hamlet en una de las facultades
dentro de unas semanas.
Hamlet está hablando con
estos dos emisarios y
se queja de lo horrible que es Dinamarca
y ellos no están de acuerdo.
Ellos dicen que no les parece que
Dinamarca sea tan horrible
y Hamlet responde: "¡Por eso
para ustedes no lo es!
Nada es bueno o malo,
se vuelve bueno o malo si
pensamos que es así".
Cuando vas por el mundo,
las cosas tienen formas y tamaños.
Esta mesa es rectangular.
Estas paredes son blancas.
La temperatura es tal y tal.
Estos son hechos sobre el mundo.
Las cosas del mundo no tienen
valores pegados a ellas.
Un acontecimiento no tiene pegada la
definición de bueno o malo.
Tu evaluación del
acontecimiento le otorga ese
valor.
Ese es el tercer punto de Epicteto.
El cuarto punto.
Epicteto destaca que hay 2
maneras de tener deseos.
Podemos pedir al mundo
que se ajuste a nuestros deseos
o podemos pedir que nuestros
deseos se ajusten al mundo.
Epicteto es partidario de lo segundo.
"No quieras que las cosas pasen
como tú quieres que pasen,
mejor desea que pasen como pasan
y tu vida irá bien".
Es una forma de garantizar al 100%
que obtendrás lo que quieres.
Desea lo que obtienes.
Si deseas lo que obtienes,
obtendrás lo que deseas.
La filosofía contemporánea tiene
una forma para describir esto.
Una forma de entenderlo
es mediante el concepto de la
dirección de ajuste.
Por ejemplo, pensemos en una
lista de la compra.
Como me había sobrado un pergamino
del contrato que firmamos con el
diablo hace unas semanas,
pensé que podría usarlo para
hacer mi lista de la compra.
Yo, sin saber nada de
Epicteto, escribo en mi lista
que me gustaría comprar
manzanas, brócoli y limones.
Voy a la tienda y el
cumplimiento de mi deseo
depende de que haya manzanas,
brócoli y limones.
Ustedes, iluminados por Epicteto, van a
la tienda, observan lo que hay,
sacan su pergamino y hacen su lista.
Manzanas, brócoli y limones.
Por ahora no hay
diferencia entre nosotros,
aunque su estrategia fue
adaptar sus deseos al mundo
y la mía fue adaptar el
mundo a mis deseos.
¿Qué pasa cuando la tienda
ya no tiene brócoli?
Yo tengo en mi lista:
manzanas, brócoli y limones.
Pero no hay brócoli.
Yo me frustro.
En cambio, ustedes adaptan
sus deseos al mundo.
Desean lo que obtienen.
Entonces, cambian su lista de la
compra y todo sale bien.
La idea de Epicteto es que si
adaptan sus deseos
a cómo son las cosas realmente,
nunca se van a frustrar.
Cuarta sugerencia.
¿Cuarta? ¿Quinta? Alguien
tiene que llevar la cuenta.
Perspectiva adecuada.
Epicteto ofrece esta extraordinaria
analogía en el séptimo párrafo.
Dice: "En un viaje cuando tu
barco está anclado,
puedes ir a buscar agua dulce,
puedes agarrar un marisco
y una verdura en el camino.
Pero debes mantenerte atento al barco
y voltear con frecuencia
por si el capitán llama.
Si llama, tendrás que
dejar esas otras cosas
para que no te amarren
y te avienten al barco como un animal".
La idea es poder ir por ahí,
disfrutar de las cosas del mundo,
pero no apegarse a ellas.
Cuando hay alguna prioridad mayor,
mantén tus pensamientos en orden.
Continúa: "Así pasa en la vida".
Saben cómo relacionarse con los
mariscos y con los jitomates.
"Así pasa en la vida también".
Cito otra vez:
"Si tienes una esposa y un hijo,
en lugar de una verdura y un
pequeño marisco,
eso tampoco puede frenarte.
Si el capitán llama, deja
todas las cosas
y corre al barco sin mirar atrás".
Tomen las estrategias que tienen
para enfrentarse a las cosas
cuya fugacidad reconocen y
adopten dichas actitudes
hacia las cosas cuya fugacidad
les resulta dolorosa.
Dice Epicteto: "Cuando tu
jarra se rompe,
piensa que es solo una jarra rota.
Cuando tu hijo se pierde,
piensa que es solo un niño perdido".
Esta es la consecuencia lógica de
la perspectiva de Epicteto
que les he estado explicando.
Sonaba muy bien cuando se trataba de
la oración de la serenidad.
Sonaba muy bien en el
ejemplo de la tienda.
Suena muy perturbadora cuando se
trata de la esposa y el hijo.
¿Qué está pasando?
Ahí les dejo esa pregunta.
Ahora, paso al segundo texto
que leímos para hoy,
un gran trabajo escrito en el siglo VI,
alrededor de 524, por alguien
cuya vida pasó casi a la inversa
de la vida de Epicteto.
Recuerden que Epicteto
nació siendo esclavo
y trató de dar sentido a su
vida de sufrimiento
una vez que consiguió su libertad.
Boecio, por el contrario, nació
en una familia noble,
en su juventud fue muy
exitoso en la política
y tuvo 2 hijos que llegaron a ser
políticos muy exitosos.
En sus últimos años, fue
encarcelado por traición.
La consolación de la filosofía
fue uno de los textos más leídos y
reproducidos de su época,
durante siglos y siglos lo
leyó casi todo el mundo,
por eso tenemos manuscritos
bellamente iluminados
que nos cuentan la historia.
Aquí está Boecio antes,
enseñando a la gente;
aquí está después,
encerrado en la cárcel.
En la cárcel, donde es
torturado y sufre,
Boecio se consuela a sí mismo
entablando una conversación
imaginaria con una figura a la
que llama Filosofía.
Aquí está Filosofía visitando
a Boecio en la prisión.
Lo que Filosofía le dice
es muy parecido a lo que
Epicteto decía.
Filosofía decía que hay una
ruleta de la suerte.
A veces las cosas
comienzan mal y mejoran.
A veces comienzan bien y empeoran.
Pero inevitablemente
hay un círculo de lo que ganas
y de lo que pierdes.
Reconocer que no podemos hacer nada,
más que aceptar que ese es el
patrón de la vida,
resulta muy liberador para Boecio.
Reconocer que el tener cosas
implica la posibilidad de
perderlas, le permite aceptar
el hecho de haber perdido
todo lo que tenía.
En la parte final de la clase
quiero volver al tema que
discutíamos antes,
la cuestión de la utilidad
filosófica de estos trabajos
en condiciones de coacción extrema.
Como ya leyeron su texto,
espero que aunque no
reconozcan a este señor
por lo menos puedan adivinar quién es.
Es el almirante James Stockdale,
que entre otras cosas,
estuvo preso junto con
John McCain en Hanoi
durante la guerra de
Vietnam y también fue
candidato independiente a
la vicepresidencia,
me parece que antes de que
ustedes nacieran.
James Stockdale, explica en sus
conmovedoras memorias
que leímos para hoy
que estudió las obras de la
tradición clásica.
Leyó a Epicteto.
Leyó a un montón de estoicos.
Leyó La Iliada. Leyó La Odisea.
Todo esto era parte de su
repertorio emocional y cognitivo
cuando le pasó esto en Vietnam:
"Era el 9 de septiembre de 1965".
Estoy leyendo de su libro.
"Volaba a 500 nudos directo a una
trampa de fuego antiaéreo
a la altura de la copa de los
árboles en un pequeño avión A4,
la cabina no tenía ni un metro de ancho
y no lo pude controlar
cuando se incendió.
Su sistema de control salió disparado.
Tras la expulsión, tuve 30 segundos
para hacer mi última
declaración de libertad
antes de aterrizar en una
pequeña aldea justo adelante.
Susurré para mí mismo:
'Ayúdenme. Cinco años
aquí por lo menos.
Estoy saliendo del mundo
de la tecnología
y entrando al mundo de Epicteto'".
"A la mano" dijo citando El
Manual, el Enchiridion,
mientras salía expulsado del avión.
Es el párrafo de apertura que
leímos hace un rato.
"Recordé la idea de que un estoico
siempre tiene archivos
separados en su mente para A,
aquellas cosas que dependen de él,
y para B, aquellas cosas que
no dependen de él.
Otra forma de decirlo, según Stockdale
"aquellas cosas que están
dentro de su poder
y aquellas cosas que están
más allá de su poder".
Otra forma de decirlo:
"aquellas cosas que están al
alcance de su libre albedrío
y aquellas cosas que están
más allá de él".
Todo sobre lo que no se tiene control,
que en la tortura del encarcelamiento
son muchas, son cosas externas.
Stockdale decía que estaría
condenado al miedo
y a la ansiedad si quisiera cambiarlas.
Necesitaba abandonar la idea de
que esas cosas cambiarían.
Sin embargo, algo sumamente importante,
es que todo lo de la
categoría A depende de mí,
está dentro de mi poder,
dentro de mi voluntad
y depende completamente de mi
interés y participación.
Esto incluye: "mis
opiniones, mis objetivos,
mis aversiones, mi dolor, mi
alegría, mis juicios,
mi actitud ante lo que pasa,
mi propio bien y mi propio mal.
Mi carácter interno"
dice Stockdale en circunstancias tan
difíciles que son casi inconcebibles.
"Mi carácter y mi respuesta a
esas cosas dependen de mí".
Continúa describiendo su
tortura usando un tropo
que hemos visto varias veces en los
textos que hemos leído.
Dice: "Al ser torturados y
liberados de la tortura, vimos
que habíamos cometido una
especie de traición
hacia nosotros mismos y hacia
nuestros principios.
Ahí entendí lo que
significaba el daño estoico"
-hace eco del daño moral
del que hablaba Jonathan Shay-
"un hombro roto, un hueso
roto en mi espalda,
una pierna rota dos veces, no
eran nada en comparación".
Epicteto: "No hay peor daño que
destruir al hombre digno
de confianza, respetable y bien
portado que hay dentro de ti".
Las situaciones extremas que
obligan a la gente a descubrir
en sí mismos aspectos de lo que son
capaces pero que no desean ver,
son las situaciones que
más daño hacen.
Cuando Platón dice: "No te hará
ningún bien obtener oro
vendiendo o esclavizando a tu hija.
Entonces, ¿por qué obtener oro
vendiendo o esclavizando tu alma?"
está expresando este mismo pensamiento.
Cuando leímos en la
discusión de Jonathan Shay
sobre la experiencia de sentir que uno
ha traicionado sus principios,
eso llevaba a un
sentimiento de daño moral.
Cuando los sujetos de
Milgram hacían cosas
que les parecían repugnantes y
temblaban, se agitaban
y sentían un desorden en sus almas.
Aquí tenemos otra respuesta
al reto de Glaucón.
Noten que aunque Stockdale
está adoptando mucho de la
idea de Epicteto,
está rechazando la parte del
jitomate y la esposa.
Rechaza la idea de Epicteto
de que las relaciones sociales
no son importantes.
En el párrafo siguiente al
que les acabo de leer,
escribe lo siguiente:
"Cuando la gente salía de su
confinamiento en solitario
y volvía al bloque normal de celdas,
era muy difícil que un
estadounidense saliera de esa
experiencia
sin responder algo como esto
cuando el prisionero de al
lado le murmuraba.
'No me hables. Soy un traidor'".
Dice Stockdale, haciendo esta especie
de escucha cuya importancia
destacaba Shay en la lectura
de la semana pasada,
"como todos éramos igual de frágiles,
parecía común que todos
respondiéramos algo como esto:
'Mira, amigo. Aquí nadie es santo.
Tenías que haber escuchado
lo que yo declaré.
Anímate, hombre. Estamos
todos juntos en esto.
¿Cómo te llamas? Háblame de ti'".
Escuchar que eras aceptado
y que los otros a tu
alrededor querían oír
tu experiencia dolorosa, vuelvo a citar,
"era para la mayoría de los
nuevos prisioneros
que acababan de salir de la primera
extorsión y del agua fría,
un cambio en sus vidas".
El texto de Stockdale nos
plantea la pregunta
de si es posible adoptar
parte de la idea de Epicteto
sin tomarla entera.
¿Es posible regular nuestros deseos
para que no esperemos del mundo más
de lo que podemos obtener?
¿Es posible hacerlo sin
perder la posibilidad
de establecer vínculos
humanos muy profundos?
Yo no sé la respuesta,
pero creo que vale la pena
reflexionar sobre la pregunta.